the White House is claiming vindication
again in the wake of the indictments
correspondent Kevin cork is outside the
president's Florida compound tonight
good evening Kevin evening there Michael
this has been a very interesting day
we've been watching all the developments
as you can well imagine not just based
on what we saw from Rosenstein but also
based on what we remember the president
had to say about the Russia
investigation oh not too terribly long
ago while the President did not respond
to shouted questions on camera this
afternoon about the revelations that
more than a dozen Russian operatives
were engaged in an effort to interfere
with the 2016 election he did take to
Twitter to weigh in Russia started their
anti US campaign in 2014 long before I
announced that I would run for president
the results of the election were not
impacted the Trump campaign did nothing
wrong no collusion Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein said today the
investigation into possible collusion is
ongoing but he also said nothing in
today's indictment indicated any
Americans knowingly took part in the
Russian scheme Sarah Huckabee Sanders
the White House press secretary issued a
statement it read in part President
Donald J Trump has been fully briefed on
this matter and is glad to see the
special counsels investigation further
indicates that there was no collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
and that the outcome of the election was
not changed or affected previously mr.
Trump called the investigation of
witch-hunt even tweeted once that it was
a quote hoax but tonight there is proof
that there was an effort by the russians
to interfere in our election even if so
far there's been no proof that anyone
involved with the Trump campaign had
anything to do with it
also tonight Mike we have learned that
White House chief of staff John Kelly
has made major changes to the way the
White House will handle security
clearance investigations in the future
we learned about this today it's a five
paved doctrine of five page document and
it basically lays out the overhaul in
this way it says it's going to require
the DOJ and the FBI to do more to follow
up on ongoing investigations we are told
that don McGann the White House chief
counsel also helped to write this
overhaul alongside John Kelly again this
is a bit of a fallout from the Rob
Porter circumstance of course a former
White House SEC staff secretary who of
course was fired not terribly long ago
Mike no question about that Kevin quark
live in West Palm Beach Florida
Kevin many facts